i am so over crying
just nothing you cry i can cry if i want
to cry those are my feelings
it's good to see you again missed this
version of you
now you try to piss me off why you do
this kind of stuff ah
oswalu sit down no i can't believe he
just stepped to kalani like that
these two got in a huge argument after
kalani got real
and told asuelu that they need more
romance in their relationship
like i don't feel like we have any super
loving
feelings with each other she also told
him that he needs to step it up in the
bedroom
i think we could use help with sex
okay but surprisingly it wasn't any of
those things that caused a swallow to
get defensive
instead it was something so minor
it wasn't anything to get that upset
over like the whole thing is just crazy
it's just psychotic
we're going to talk about what exactly
sent asuelu launching at his wife
and my takeaway from all of this plus
andre had his first day at work with
libby's family
and it was everything you probably
expected dude you're saying that you're
giving this property to me no no per
usual
andre was acting entitled and then
libby's sister stormed in accusing him
of trying to take her job
he's shadiest period and charlie
charlie was ready to fight at any given
moment you're going to do what
today to do or you're not going to work
y'all go ahead and take a deep breath
because trust me
wait hold on a second no shut up we're
gonna need it for this one
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicia
there were some men acting like children
during this episode let's go ahead and
start with kalani and asuelu's fight
kicking it off from the top i need to
like step up my homemaking game
kalani took her sister colini furniture
shopping
for this new house that she is really
thinking about buying with asuelu
because according to him moving out of
her parents house
will make him act better while they were
at the store
kalani revealed to her sister that they
need a house with three rooms
so a swellow could have a game room
where he can also sleep
so you guys generally sleep in different
rooms
he uh basically comes in the room when
you know he wants
to have sex and that's it to make
matters worse
kalani revealed that there is no romance
in her relationship
like there's nothing we don't it feels
like i live with a friend and what she
is getting from asuelu isn't even good
roommate with benefits are they even
benefits
not really like there's nothing we don't
go out on dates
we don't have alone time i'm like
constantly thinking of him and thinking
of what he would like or what he would
want and that's never reciprocated at
all
it needs to be like no you can't just
walk in and blank me and then walk back
out and go to sleep
well i think it is partly my fault
because
he he wasn't taught to do anything
wait wait wait wait how is that your
fault
you didn't raise him kalani went on to
say that asuelu has no idea
what real love is because he didn't see
it from his parents
i feel this need to nurture him and
teach him things because he is the
father of my kids
i have no idea how many times i've used
a dude's upbringing
to justify why they treated me like crap
that used to be my go-to excuse
now while the way someone was brought up
can certainly affect their adult
relationships
it's no excuse for being an [ __ ]
pardon my language but i'm just saying
there comes a moment in everyone's life
where you can choose
to be different than what you saw
growing up she deserves
so much more and kalani can't make that
choice for asuelu
he has to do that so i feel this need to
nurture him and teach him things because
he is the father of my kids
but then that's where my relationship
that's romantic dies cause you can't
have a romantic relationship with
someone that you're mommying
you're asking literally for the bare
minimum from your husband
you want to feel loved and i think
that's at the very least that's what you
should feel i am so
glad she has her sister because let's be
real
not everyone on the show has someone to
talk sense into them
and i get where she's coming from yes we
as women are nurturers
but sometimes our desire to nurture
can make us blind to the truth we end up
walking around
sacrificing ourselves because we think
someone needs us
when the truth is aswell survived before
kalani came into his life
and god willing he will continue to
survive
if she chooses to leave talking with my
sister made me realize that there's a
lot that me and oscar will need to talk
about and a lot that we need to fix i
know we've been getting along better but
like we're kind of in a really horrible
place in our marriage once kalani made
it home
she sat down to talk with asuelu she
brought up how they need to work on
romance and their sex life
do you know what a sex toy is no what is
that
but as i mentioned earlier that wasn't
what set him off
it was when kalani started talking about
how he could be more considerate
and she innocently used her brother as
an example
i bring you a pizza you do bring me
pizza why didn't
why didn't mention that my brother also
brings me food sometimes too
so we're not talking about your brother
yeah but i'm saying
i think your definition of romance and
love is different than my definition
you just say oh my brother bring your
foot i'm not talking about your partner
putting your foot
well someone was triggered if we talk
about you and me and joke about brad
is so annoying and that's what we need
to
work on how you can talk to me asuelu
went from zero to ten
in a matter of seconds oh my brother
bring me food we're not talking about
your
brother kalani explained that this is
the perfect example of how their
relationship goes we're really good and
we're having fun and then the littlest
thing can set him off and it's usually
the dumbest thing what i still can't
believe is how he just stepped to her
like she was a man on the street i
missed this version of you now
you tried to piss me off why you do this
kind of stuff
to be honest at first i thought the
brother was just
the tipping point and deep down aswell
was really just mad
because kalani told the world his sexes
kind of is like meh anyways but then
common sense kicked in
and just watching you can tell that it's
much deeper than that
i think it's even deeper than what
asuelu claims
i think it's not fair because kalani
tells me what she wants and i express
my feelings to how i feel and she starts
crying
so she not listened what's my point and
what i trying to say
well it's kind of hard to listen to
someone who's cursing you out
after this kalani said that if this is
who asuelu really is
she doesn't see them buying a house
together nor does she see them in a
relationship in the future
it sounds like she's at her breaking
point but i also feel like we've been
here with these two before
so time will tell wait a minute
who said you were listening to property
i never told you you were gonna get the
listing on this probably but you're
gonna get the whole thing
now all right let's quickly touch on
andre's explosive fight with elizabeth's
siblings
on his first day of work as we know
andre is coming off from being a
stay-at-home dad
oh baby that's sweet
the baby was like yes i'm staying with
mommy
she told her daddy bye twice
bye-bye bye-bye daddy let's get out of
here see ya
after andre left the house he met up
with libby's dad to go check out a home
that they're flipping
now chuck he has good intentions he's
helping andre because he wants to help
his daughter which
is understandable but at the same time
he's also causing drama because he's
tiptoeing around his other kids who
really don't want andre joining the team
the hell are you doing here why am i not
here with you guys is the question
i told you i was going to do a
walk-through you did it no you did it
no i heard from libby on top of that
here comes andre lying on chuck in front
of his face
i guess in an attempt to manipulate the
situation
and be messy dude you're saying that
you're
giving this property to me no no
i have a contract with my dad in our
family business
to be his listening agent and andre
thinks that
that's what he's going to be doing he's
shady
period following becky's storming in
there was a back and forth between her
charlie and andre for a minute
she was pissed thinking that andre is
trying to take her job
no no no this is not happening and
charlie was upset that andre thinks he
can just
jump the ranks and not start off doing
work as a handyman
take your truck run a trailer and get
all the out of here
no i need to be here
because if it's gonna come andrei's
ego causes so much unnecessary drama in
his life
and in the lives of those around him i
mean who told him he was too good for
hard work
the best of the best have worked the
hardest i'm glad we aired this out
chuck eventually reeled things back in
but his daughter
left him with one stark warning you need
to not
like worry about like the listing
because that's way down the road but dad
i'm telling you
if you give him this listing
there are going to be major problems
they already are major problems
they're right there well next week it
looks like andre is going to have
way more serious things to worry about
than becoming a real estate king
innovation officers have access to
records
in foreign countries did you ever commit
any violation of any laws anywhere
in the world no are you sure
if you hide any information you will be
put in deportation
tell the truth andre all right 90 day
fans fam
to make sure you stay updated on all the
latest news coming out the 90 day
universe
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time
you